can we start with ukraine is labour
still foursquare behind the prime
minister
yes look we we need to see robust and
united
international action to prevent the
situation in ukraine from escalating
there is uh there are two sides to this
there is the side of ukraine which is an
argument for freedom democracy
self-determination and on the other side
you have russian aggression so we stand
four square united here within the uk
and squarely alongside our nato allies
that's exactly where we should be but of
course alongside robust action abroad we
also need to see robust action at home
from the government particularly
tackling uh illicit dirty russian money
which is flowing through the city of
london and unfortunately it seems also
flowing through the coffers of the
conservative party so i think there's a
lot more to be done to clean up our act
here at home to stop the city of london
being the destination of choice for
russian kleptocrats and money laundering
well let's take those two things in turn
let's start with uh abroad
are you at all worried that there's a
danger that
this thing could escalate inadvertently
into a situation where
there is a conflict that as the prime
minister has
said in the last 24 hours
could engulf europe
well let's hope not and there is still
time for president putin to do the right
thing
we hope the situation will not escalate
further in fact all of the efforts right
across the nato alliance are on
de-escalation as as it should be but
president putin should also be in no
doubt about the resolve of the uk on a
cross-party basis the resolve of nato
working across the multilateral alliance
to take robust action if president putin
makes the choice to escalate the
situation further
so you support you support the
deployments
of which the prime minister spoke
yesterday in the black sea and in
neighboring state to ukraine
we support the government of ukraine we
support the ukraine armed forces that's
the right thing to do and it's also
important to send a message to our
allies right across the region that the
uk is with them this is you know the
nato alliance has been the cornerstone
of western defense and democracy uh
since it was created in 1949 and and the
then labor government led by clement
atlee played a critical um role of which
we're enormously proud of in the labour
party and it's important that today
president putin understands that
alliance remains strong it is by its
nature a defensive alliance we want to
see de-escalation of the situation but
the uk stands ready to support the
government of ukraine as we're already
doing and also support nato allies right
across the region
all right well let's take the other arm
of your policy which is domestic
sanctions and
the pursuit of dirty money as you called
it
um i think you heard what uh mr
cleverley had to say do you accept his
assurances that the government really
means it this time
not really because we've had the
cross-party russia report of the
intelligence and security committee
of the house of commons which set out a
whole range of
recommendations to help clean up our act
here at home and to protect our
democracy
from russian interference that report
has not been implemented we have an
elections bill going through parliament
right now which ironically would make it
easier for foreign money to pollute our
politics we've got to put a stop to that
so
when boris johnson threatens tough
sanctions against president putin he
knows he'll have our support in
implementing those sanctions but our
message to the prime minister is that he
and his government should have acted far
sooner to clean up money laundering in
the city of london and also to clean up
the conservative parties act when it
comes to the donations it receives from
individuals linked to the russian
government
you um a couple of weeks ago your party
put out uh a list of
named individuals who you
said had given money to the conservative
party and uh you implied that they would
influence policy uh in a way
advantageous to mr putin
what evidence do you have that any of
these people
has had any influence on what the
government does
we'll take a look at the sunday papers
today which no no no whatever
you put this out two weeks ago degree
evidence that you have that's an
important thing they have any influence
whatsoever
so we know that donors have an enormous
degree of influence over the policies
and priorities of the conservative
government
that's been known for some time and has
been laid bare in today's sunday
newspapers
you've got people like the chinookans a
former deputy finance minister
in president putin's regime his wife has
given more than two million pounds to
the conservative party so i think there
are questions for them to answer on this
and
with respect if somebody said that about
is making the right decisions for the
right reasons with respect mr streeting
if somebody said that about a labour
party donor you would be using the word
smear
let me ask you again
take miss uh mr chnukin what evidence do
you have that mr newkin has had
any influence on what the government has
done what is it that he has asked for
that you can say the government has done
well today we learn that his wife who's
given significant amounts of money to
the conservative party has been
attending meetings with the prime
minister's former chief of staff lord
lister
on this advisory board for the
conservative party where donors have a
direct route into number 10 to influence
government policy so i think the
government have got serious questions to
ask about that
of course we're particularly concerned
in the context of our discussion this
morning about those individuals with
links to president putin's regime but
this applies more broadly in terms of
our politics which is that it can't just
be big money donors that call the shots
in our democracy we need to make sure
the government is acting in the interest
of all of the people of the united
kingdom not just those with big wallets
funding the conservative party
we are if i may say so talking about
newspaper reporting and i i want to be
clear with everybody who is watching
that as far as we know there is no
evidence to uh
support
the suggestion that uh that that uh
there has been specific influence but
let's move on if i may quickly to your
area of responsibility and covert
if mr johnson lifts all the covered
restrictions will you support that
well i'm particularly concerned about
the end of free testing i mean it's a
bit like being 2-1 up with 10 minutes
left of play and subbing your best
defender we are not out of the woods yet
on covid and it's important that when
the government publishes its plan for
living with clover tomorrow that it is a
robust plan that enables everyone to
live well with kovid we published our
plan back in january and i came on your
program to talk about it then there are
a number of sensible steps that can and
should be taken to ensure that we can
live well with covid without impacting
on people's lives livelihoods and
liberties access to free testing right
now given the prevalence of the virus
given the fact we're still asking people
to isolate at home if they have the
virus if they're infectious it's a
really critical tool acting on sick pay
would also make an enormous difference
and and frankly it's inexplicable the
government haven't acted already on this
and just this week we saw businesses and
unions the federation of small
businesses the trade union congress
aligned on this so and i i tend to find
i've got a church with near the um choir
singing next to me when you've got
business and unions singing from the
same hint sheet it's usually a good idea
to dance to their tune because they're
you know they're they're and they're
right on this we've got to act on sick
pay so there are a number of things the
government can do to make sure that we
can live well with the virus and i don't
think boris johnson and his government
should be complacent about the fact that
whether it's a million or so clinically
extremely vulnerable people who are
really worried lots of pensioners and
older people who are still worried about
the virus making sure we've got sensible
measures in place like free testing
gives people the confidence to go about
their daily lives safe in the knowledge
that they're protected from the risk of
the virus okay mr trading we're running
out of time but i i'd be remiss if i
didn't ask you a very quick question and
a quick answer if i may uh about the
report this week that labor is planning
not
to put resources into seats which uh are
targeted by the liberal democrats um
short question really is
confronted with the possibility of
another tory government or an
understanding with the liberal democrats
wouldn't you personally choose an
understanding with the liberal democrats
well i can tell you there have been no
talks formal or informal with the
liberal democrats uh it is just a simple
matter of fact that there are a number
of seats at the next election where the
liberal democrats are in contention the
labour party isn't far more seats where
the labour party is in contention and
the liberal democrats are not and as as
political parties we will obviously
target our resources where we can to
make sure we win as many seats as
possible get rid of this rotten tory
government and have a credible serious
prime minister in kierstama focused on
the real issues facing the country
whether that's the rising cost of living
or the or the need to make sure we
rebuild out of the pandemic and that's
what labour's focused on
okay i'm taking that as a yes good
morning thank you very much mr streeting